Owen how are you I'm good thank you how
are you did you bring any snacks I'm
hungry
um I did uh they're in the car though
okay
um I think of Snickers is in there a lot
of stickers yes what is it about Carl
nargle that just has the ladies lining
up
well I think it's got to be the hair
right
um yeah and he kind of has that his look
is sort of um
it's kind of That 70s denim look that uh
maybe is coming back in style or
um you know Carl if that is if you stick
with a look long enough
it can sometimes roll back around and I
think that's the case with Carl our goal
is pretty simple
I want to help you get what's in here
and just splash it onto there don't
worry it's not rocket science
it's harder
now Bob Ross I think we can say inspired
by Rob Ross a little bit he was kind of
famous for this this ASMR which has come
back around do you know what ASMR is
what is that the
um tell me what that is it's kind of
like when you talk like the senator yeah
yeah we were doing that the other day we
were doing some
um uh kind of publicity stuff for the
movie where we were doing that kind of
in character yeah I didn't know that was
the name the am ASMR ASMR I if if you
put in the spot I could not tell you
what that means but I mean there is
something very soothing obviously about
his voice and the way that you know uh
people still kind of respond to it and I
think also seeing somebody
um create something
um in 30 minutes is kind of a nice gives
you a nice sense of accomplishment
watching it yeah can you show me the
Carl nargle ASMR
[Music]
those little things that might just pass
unnoticed but when you look at them and
give yourself the chance to be thrilled
by the ordinary it can be really
exciting
it was really nice
so I want to Pivot for a second
even as I'm doing it it's kind of
putting I didn't of course know where I
was going but it did start to yeah maybe
that's why those asmrs are popular
because even doing them or listening to
them has sort of a meditative quality I
got a little Zen yeah so last month I'm
in a theater watching a movie called
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania yes
and we get to the post credits and lo
and behold a little scene from Loki
season two in there that's right yes uh
what do they call those they're called
uh Easter eggs or something I think uh
but yes there was
um I guess they have kind of a little uh
shot of Tom Hiddleston and I and
Jonathan Majors from Loki season two and
I think that's coming out into the
summer or September yeah how much Wilder
are we getting now that the Kings have
been Unleashed I know I think it's going
to be just I think it's going to get uh
yeah very wild an Oscar winner
oh it's so exciting that was incredible
every time I saw him winning something
it was another speech that just kind of
you know was a tearjerker that was so
moving and
um
even kind of you know when we were
working on this last summer he I think
his character that he plays in uh
in this low-key season too I think we'll
we'll not be a I think people will be
excited even though that was so great
obviously the character that he won an
Oscar for I think people are going to
love his character in this if I had to
put you on the spot and ask you to paint
me a picture right now what would you
paint
I might do sort of a uh gritty kind of
downtown scene because that's what I'm
seeing as I look around and maybe kind
of a Banksy uh thing
um you know sort of some uh some comment
some uh little witty comment on
um on life and uh yeah I wish this I
hope this is how I find out that you're
actually Banksy
[Music]